- Pizza could be an
aphrodisiac if you banged
after eating pizza once.
- All the time I bang after eating pizza.
(suggestive music)
- I think strawberries are erotic.
- I don't think aphrodisiacs are real,
except maybe green M&M's.
- Pizza.
- Yep.
- Chocolate chip cookies.
- Oooh! You know what is an aphrodisiac?
Money.
(suggestive music)
Does this mean that you just get horny
at every picnic?
- Like, that's sexual.
- I'd eat more of it,
but keep my clothes on.
- Now it's juicy,
- It's red.
- After each one, I'm just
gonna yell do you have a boner?
(suggestive music)
- I can't really see myself
being turned on by avocados.
- I don't find it sexy.
- No, not really, I mean--
- It doesn't turn me on.
- I mean, maybe it might
turn some people on
because this is in the middle of it,
and they might--
- A hard ball.
- Doesn't work for me. Not a turn on.
- Mmmmm.
- Do you have a boner?
- Yeah, I'm not feeling anything.
(suggestive music)
- There's really nothing
about this that I could see
as relating to anything sexual.
- No, I don't know.
Not sexual whatsoever.
- Yeah.
- See that? Now that's sexy.
(both laughing)
- Now, that is kind of
a turn on, the banana.
- This idea that this is
like a phallic object,
and then you just bite out of it?
- Eating a banana will always look sexual.
- Bananas make me gassy.
That's not a turn on.
(suggestive music)
- Chocolate is better than sex.
It's the texture of it.
When you break it.
- Yeah, I think this is sexy.
Especially an expensive box.
- You could probably
slide into the bedroom
with some chocolate.
- If you're turned on by it, then I would,
I guess--
- That's what I mean.
- in turn be turned on by it.
Why don't you have some more?
(suggestive music)
- Ewww. So fishy.
- Opening them, and slurping them,
and all of that sort of thing.
It's sort of supposed to be
like a sexy kind of thing.
- Mmm-mmm. No.
No, no, no.
- This is sexy, hmmm?
- Mmm-hmmm.
- Out of all the aphrodisiacs
- Yeah.
- that we've just eaten,
- this ruined it.
- It gives you sort of a
virile situation sometimes.
- It would be a turn on if
I went on a date and someone
ordered the food.
- As like the appetizer?
Then I'm, then I'm horny,
because he paid for them.
(suggestive music)
I don't think aphrodisiacs are real.
But I think there are sense
memories tied to certain things.
- I changed my mind, actually.
I do think they're real.
- Yeah, you combine
this, have some oysters,
maybe some chocolate,
- A banana. And wine.
- A banana, and you put in the avocado,
you're going to be (bleep)ing
- all day.
- for three days.
- You're going to need a lot of condoms.
- Yeah.
- The banana's the tease,
The chocolate is the foreplay,
and the wine is the climax.